[Music]
the fund XX started actually at a time
of transition for me
I was really reflecting on What mattered
to me and what I wanted to do I was
watching syndicates start to happen
where you start to have groups of people
invest together but what I saw in these
groups is that they were still majority
men
in a world that should be more
accessible than ever it was actually
worse than numbers you'd see elsewhere
the fundexx has a pre-seed venture fund
investing in women CEOs
will tell you that 22 percent of Angel
Investors are women when I would go look
at the most active syndicates on
angelist it was three percent three out
of a hundred LPS were women so I called
Allison stoloff my GSB classmate and I
said Allison we have to make a page of
just women investors and she was like
okay let's do it
I had been having conversations with
Jenny fielding and they had been
building this fun concept which was
essentially Community Driven BC they
were investing in the local ecosystem in
New York and several other cities and
Jenny said well why don't you think
about this community that you're
building and applying it to investing in
women CEOs and see if that makes sense
see if there's a story and we found that
companies that are led by women CEOs
typically have about 250k Less in
funding than their peers a lot of that
has to do with bias that's pervasive and
many ecosystems but especially at the
precede stage all you have is who you
are I think it's much harder for people
to want to take a bet on women at the
early stages when there's no data we're
usually that first check into that
business believing in that female
founder from from day one fortunately
the mission res with many people the
fund XX stands out in the investment
industry for reasons one is around our
focus on women we are very unique in
that we invest in women and are backed
by women at every level and then on the
other side of it we're unique in the
industry in our model typically when
you're a limited partner or an investor
you're writing a check and then you sit
in and wait and you watch and with the
fund XX these investors are able to
share their expertise with this you know
incredible group of female Founders
we're really
taking it outside of the individual and
making it about the community
I think the biggest impact that the GSB
has had on me is that it is a place that
reminds me to think big I think the GSB
is great at encouraging students to go
take risks to spend this time at the GSB
really figuring out what you want to do
trying different things when I think
about Stanford's motto change lives
change organizations change the world I
think about impact I think about the
immediate nucleus and then
how can that continue to expand what are
the artifacts that I leave behind and
how do I help make a difference and what
do I do that's still going to be here I
get so excited about this power of
community we have incredible Founders
and operators sharing ideas sharing
perspectives those are the times when I
get most inspired because I'm able to
see the size of this network that we
build in this community
Sylvia and I had this belief that women
succeed at the same rates as men when
given the same access to resources and
network ultimately the best world for
everyone is a world that represents
everyone and we're we need to continue
to focus and to make an impact is
to bring people into the ecosystem who
otherwise weren't in the ecosystem and I
hope that in 10 years we are focused on
the next
thing because we've been able to make a
meaningful dent I hope that the fund XX
will not be considered a diversity Fund
in 10 years it would be great if there
was much more of a Level Playing Field I
think another kind of success metric
ride is we're a venture capital fund and
so we're measured on our return so my
hope is that we have some billion dollar
exits that will show people that women
are worth investing in and that women
can be just as successful as men when
given access to the same resources in
the same network my name is Allison
strolloff and I'm a partner at the fund
XX my name is Sylvia cuyal and I'm a
partner at the fund access
[Music]